cela fait bientôt trente années que
patrick modiano écrit ses romans
une vingtaine à ce jour et dans son cas
on peut bien parler d'une oeuvre en
cours puisque fondée sur des témoignages
et des réminiscences elle reconquiert
impasse et imaginer en l'espèce les
troubles années de l'occupation avec
dora bruder qu'il publie chez gallimard
il poursuit sa trajectoire concentriques
laissant de plus en plus de place à une
bouleversante autobiographie oui dora
bruder à exister et disparus en 1941 à
l'âge de 15 ans ou si noël du mois sa
semblable une enfant juive en butte à la
persécution est promise à la déportation
pour tenter de retrouver sa trace
patrick modiano cette fois abandonne les
beaux quartiers de l'ouest de la
capitale
il aborde barbès le boulevard ornano les
banlieues de l'est
et cette usine westinghouse de sevran
quelque part dans un faubourg baptisés
freins ville un bloc de silence autour
de ces inconnus disparus dont modiano
semble le seul à se souvenir un vide
tragique au détour d'un indice des
personnages réels
le père du romancier mais léa d'obscurs
trafic sa mère comédienne le dr
ferrières qui soigna si mal artaud à
rodez où jean jauzion qui écrivit un
homme marche dans la ville une immense
tristesse s'abat sur le lecteur car
l'oubli semble inéluctable alors que
c'est la mémoire seul qui fait vivre les
morts